new zealand's prime minister yasinda
arden has again declared victory over
the coronavirus she said restrictions in
auckland would be lifted after no new
cases were confirmed
for 10 days new zealand appeared to snap
out the virus back in may but a new
outbreak hit auckland in august
and iceland has introduced new
restrictions following a spike in
infections there the latest wave of
infections is thought to be
much higher than earlier this year bars
clubs and gyms
all shut down gatherings of more than 20
people
now banned
well the world health organization is
describing italy as an example of
best practices in dealing with the
coronavirus
officials are praising government
policies and the discipline
shown by the italian public dwu's george
mathis has been to milan to find out how
a city
once at the epicenter of that country's
outbreak
is coping now
she lived through the spanish flu the
two world wars and now
she survived covet 19. fatima negrini is
108 years old
during the first wave of the coronavirus
in italy she watched many friends in her
nursing home
die
i've been through so many things in my
life and i'm still here
it looks as if jesus christ doesn't want
me
care homes were hard hit in the early
stages of the pandemic
when milan was at the epicentre of the
outbreak
more than half of the 33 000 lives lost
to covet 19
in italy were here in the city and the
surrounding lombardy region
wanda gatti a volunteer with the white
cross
provided emergency support during the
most acute stage of the crisis
she captured some impressions of the
chaos on her phone
we lived in a very traumatic experience
like a tsunami something that in at the
moment
arrived and changed completely
everything
so from that moment we changed our
behavior our approach to
the life people are legally obliged to
wear masks in
all crowded places from 6 p.m to 6 a.m
and many also keep theirs on during the
day
another reason infection rates are
rising slowly
is the long-term effect of italy's harsh
lockdown
which kept people confined to their
homes for months on end
professor maria ritachis mondo says
there's no magic formula
for other countries to follow italy is
not perfect
and it certainly can't go it alone i
think
an important thing is
to think at the european health
to have the same protocol of therapy
the same to exchange experiences
the same current thing not just they
look
localized health but just matter you
know european
strategy to face the viruses
the professor also has high hopes for a
rapid testing scheme
the government plans to roll out in
schools that's good news
for matteo and his sister victoria they
started class only two weeks ago
and don't want to go back to
homeschooling your sparrow
and get a bit closer to each other
without having to keep our distance all
the time
this cemetery is a bitter reminder of
milan's collective trauma
the 128 people laid to rest here were
brought here
from overcrowded hospitals and morgues
relatives who may not have been able to
claim bodies because of the tough
quarantine restrictions or because they
were sick themselves
can move their loved ones from here to
other parts of the cemetery within a
period of two years
for sanitary reasons march in april 2020
changed the north of italy forever
though public support for ongoing
restriction remains high
many now fear fear approaching winter
and we have some breaking news coming in
european commission president was la
fonda lyon says she
is self-isolating until tuesday
after she attended a meeting with
someone who tested positive for
coronavirus she said she tested negative
last thursday but
would be testing again today and we'll
have more details
as they come in let's get you up to
speed now on some of the other
developments in the pandemic new york
mayor bill de blasio is seeking to close
all
non-essential businesses and schools in
nine neighborhoods that
have been identified as virus clusters
up to 500 000 people
could be affected by the proposed
shutdown
the french capital paris is being placed
on maximum alert for two weeks to curb a
new rise in infections there bars will
remain closed
restaurants will have to implement
stricter sanitary protocols the new
measures
take effect tuesday in the philippines
some 25 million students
have started classes at home president
duterte has ordered schools to remain
shot
until a vaccine becomes widely available
you